is it really surprising that the most  powerful man in the world should be a  figure of controversy we as a population  on this planet have been looking for a  savior we're talking about a Bailey  whose very existence is not telling us  the truth challenges our own sense of  priority in the universe human beings  have a horrible track record of  following people with great power  corrupts and absolute power corrupts  absolutely chaos maybe he's just a guy  trying to do the right they know better  now that what he can do that no one has  asked what he should  that's how it starts the fever the rage  the feeling of powerlessness that turns  good men  cruel  tell me do you plead  at all  you  you